so I decided to take a look at cnn.com a
popular news site to get started I
opened up dev tools by pressing command
option I you can see the dev tools here
here's the HTML so we're in the timeline
now I'm gonna see what happens when the
page loads so I'm gonna press command
shift our reload the page and we can see
all the events of the page load laid out
in the timeline here well this is cool
for desktop but I wonder what this looks
like on mobile
luckily Chrome gives us the option of
seeing what it looks like on mobile I'm
gonna press this button to open up the
console there we go and we can see that
there's a tab up here emulation so I
click on this I see the google nexus 5
and I press emulate so now we're looking
at cnn.com from a mobile perspective but
this looks weird I'm going to fix the
screen a little bit and I'm gonna
refresh the page by doing command shift
R and now we see the mobile version of
CNN on the left and our timeline on the
right let me get rid of this bottom part
by pressing escape and move the screen
over to give ourselves a little bit more
room and let's take a look at the
timeline so I've selected about the
first second or so of events let me see
them in a little bit more detail all
right so we see a request here for a
page cnn.com slash so I'm gonna click on
this and open up the details click on
cnn.com and we should see what this file
is scrolling down this should look
pretty familiar it's just an HTML
document going back to the timeline
let's get rid of some of these details
we can see a lot of events up here if we
click on this filter button it lets us
get rid of some of them so we can just
look at what we want I just want to see
the loading events so I'll get rid of
scripting rendering and painting and now
we can see the request for the homepage
and the response as we're receiving data
cnn.com finishes loading we got that
HTML file and then we start to parse the
HTML and it looks like in parsing it by
opening up this step we see that we
requested CSS and JavaScript
after that scrolling down we can see
more requests for all of the scripts
images and CSS files that are needed to
load the page